You know how in games like chess,
tennis, or even Settlers of Katan, you
can't just make the same moves every
time and expect to win? Well, writing
isn't all that different. If you want to
write well, you can't just focus on your
own moves. You've got to pay attention
to what the other person is doing. So,
what moves does the writer make? And
more importantly, how can understanding
the writer's playbook help you get
unstuck when you're facing the blank
page? By the way, if you're new here,
I'm William. I spent 10 years as an
English professor and a writing coach at
one of the top science and tech
universities in South Korea. And now I
help busy experts write books that
matter. So, if that sounds like you, be
sure to grab my free newsletter, Writer
Science. Link is down below the like
button. The trick is to treat writing
like a twoplayer game. You move, they
respond, you adjust. While you're
writing, you don't just think about what
you want to say. You think about what
move your reader is going to make next
and you write in response to that move.
Have you ever noticed how your best
ideas come out whenever you're talking
to someone? Like you start explaining
something and then halfway through
something clicks. Why is it so much
easier when we're speaking than it is
when we're writing? Well, this is what I
call the experts curse. So experts,
which is you, by the way, I believe we
all have our own domain of expertise.
Even if it's from your own life, you are
expert on some topic. So whatever the
subject of your expertise, all experts
struggle more than beginners due to a
psychological effect. That is the
smarter you are and the more well-versed
in your subject you are, the harder
writing becomes. I mean, I think we've
all felt like this crushing weight of
everything that you could possibly say.
And whenever you feel this kind of
pressure, every sentence feels
inadequate. And so you start, you write,
you delete, you start again. It never
ends. And it's important to understand
first that feeling this is actually a
really good sign because it means that
you're starting to pay attention to the
quality of your own writing and you're
starting to imagine the reader on the
other side of the page. Like it's just
so unfair the confidence that amateurs
have whenever they set out to write
about these topics. But the reason they
have this confidence is because they
don't even know what they don't know.
they they think they're a master at it
and so they just walk out strididently
talking about this topic. And of course
it's really unfair. But I just want to
say that honestly if you are feeling
this pressure, this kind of need to make
your writing perfect, which of course
you'll never actually achieve. But if
you're feeling that, I think you're
moving in the right direction because
you are now thinking about your readers.
And of course that can be crippling and
we're going to work through that. But
just at the start, notice as you start
to feel this pressure, as you start to
feel like your writing isn't good
enough, you are moving in the right
direction. You're no longer looking at
yourself and thinking, "I'm so great and
I'm so smart like the amateurs." You are
now thinking, "Oh, no. I've got an
audience. There's somebody on the other
side of this paper who I respect and I
want to deliver them something of
value." So, that pressure is a really
good sign. But of course, we need to
break through that and or at least learn
how to work with it. Because if you
don't, then your ideas are never going
to reach the people who most need it.
This is what's known as the Dunning
Krueger effect of writing. That's when
people who have limited knowledge have
supreme confidence and the experts get
paralyzed by self-doubt. You know, take
any subject uh meditation. You know, a
beginner who went on one retreat, you
know, a three-day retreat now starts an
entire blog about it. Whereas a
neuroscientist who's been studying about
this and publishing about this can't get
the first sentence out. And honestly,
the reason this happens is because the
beginner, the amateur doesn't know
enough to be scared. Now, the expert on
the other hand, they know too much. And
more importantly, they know what they
don't know. They know about their own
knowledge gaps and their own
limitations. But I really think the way
to break through this problem is to
understand that writing is not just a
medium for capturing what you know. It's
a method for figuring out what you
think. Like this thing that I call
expert writing. What is it? It's people
who are using writing to generate value.
And I think that's the best kind of
non-fiction writing because I think
value is what drives people to read
non-fiction. Okay. So it all comes down
to value. And if you're writing
valuably, it means that you're thinking
thoughts that have never been thought
before. You're not just doing this
pastiche AI writing where you're
shuffling around other people's ideas
into these new patterns. No, you're
generating new thoughts. You're thinking
about problems and questions and you're
solving them. That's the way that
experts use writing to generate value.
Okay? But the thing is these questions,
these problems, this new knowledge that
you're generating through your writing,
well, it's too complex to sort out in
your head. So you need writing to hold
these pieces, you know, as you work
through them together and to smash them
together. Like I almost think of the
blank page at this phase of writing to
be like a laboratory where you're just
testing things. You're putting them
together. You don't quite know. You're
experimenting. And that is how new
knowledge gets created. And that kind of
process is very akin to the talking
process because when you're talking, you
are thinking out loud. Now, that's kind
of a cliche phrase, thinking out loud.
But we all know what that is. When you
call your friend, you just want to talk
and suddenly you kind of discover the
idea that you've been sitting on. Well,
it works the same way with your writing.
There's something special about your
voice. So we have to understand that you
know when we get stuck in writing that's
because we're already at the next phase
right we're already dealing with the
pressure of imagining somebody else
reading our paper but I'm saying don't
go there yet you need this first phase
where you are using your writing to do
your thinking. You're using your writing
to invite these ideas to emerge. you're
gonna work on one piece over here and
then another piece over there and you're
going to go on a tangent here and it's
going to be a mess. But if you just kind
of keep on showing up and you keep
chiseling at it, suddenly new ideas
start to emerge and novel solutions to
these problems and questions start to
appear. So that's my best advice to
breaking through this resistance is to
understand this two-phase strategy of
writing. So, here's how to break through
that wall of perfectionism is first
start writing before you know where
you're going. I think the easiest way to
do this is just to set a 20inut timer
and do a brain dump. You should be doing
this every day. In the artist community,
they have this uh practice known as
morning pages. Okay? And that's the kind
of thing I'm talking about where you
just flush out your ideas. Now, morning
pages um from the book uh the artist's
way, they advise just writing about
anything that comes to mind. Now, of
course, readers aren't going to be so
interested in your journal and your, you
know, your dream log and that kind of
thing. So, you could do that, but of
course, it's also helpful to uh do this
kind of freewriting with your topic or
with your question in mind. So, a
version of this artist way uh morning
pages method would be to write the
question that you want to answer in your
essay at the or or your book or your
chapter at the top of the page and then
for 10 or 20 minutes just focusing on
that question freeright. You do let
anything come to mind but you still kind
of keep your center of gravity in this
question or this problem that your
readers will find valuable. Second, it
is helpful to talk it out. Okay, so I am
a big fan of using voiceto text um
transcription services. You have these
on your phone now. And sometimes it's
just a really easy way to kind of get
the juices flowing and kind of empty out
your thoughts about these ideas. You can
get an automatic transcript as soon as
it comes out. If you want to use AI to
clean it up, you can do that. And and
and then you have some raw material that
you can start working with. And finally,
I think you just need to embrace the
mess at this stage. Like, we really need
to be strict in understanding that this
first stage of writing, it's a totally
different process. It has nothing to do
with what we're going to show readers.
It really doesn't. In fact, I usually
advise writers to not even try to edit
their first drafts. Like, their first
draft is literally going in the bottom
of a drawer if it's on paper or it's
it's staying on your hard drive, right?
Nobody is going to read that. You do
this first draft of writing for you, for
you to work out your own ideas. And then
when it's starting to make sense to you,
you set that aside and you start a new
draft, and that's your reader's draft.
And if you're really strict about this
distinction between the writer's draft
and the reader draft, then it be I think
it becomes so much more like liberating
to just feel free in your writing in
that first writer's draft. And writers,
we don't enjoy that feeling of freedom
enough. You know, I think if you look at
like professional artists, painters, uh
potters, you know, I I think whenever I
see people who who have really developed
this craft, you know, they they just
feel so free. They like a painter is
just going to show up to their studio
and they don't have a solid sense of
what they're going to paint that day,
but they pick up the colors and they
move it around and they let the image
emerge. You know, they and they leave a
lot of room for exploration. And I think
as writers, especially non-fiction
writers, you know, we tend to be a
pretty um analytical bunch. And so I
think we really need to bring in this
kind of an artistic process into our
writing. So that's why I say there is a
writing phase and that's just for you
and there is a reading phase and we're
going to talk about that in a second.
But this writing phase, let it be messy
because nobody's going to see it. All
right. But here's the problem with most
writing advice. Most writing advice
trains you to succeed in school but fail
in the real world. And this is what I
call the school writing trap. So, as you
might know, I'm an English professor and
you know what are we doing? We're always
assigning these these essays and these
assignments. What is that? What are we
trying to do there? Well, if you really
think about it from the teacher's
perspective, right? Why do we give
students these writing assignments? We
give them a writing assignment to
demonstrate their understanding. Okay?
So, let's say I read, you know, I I
assign a book, the students have to go
home and read a novel. I want to make
sure they've read that novel and not
only read it, but thought about it. And
so, I ask them to write an essay. So,
what's the what's the goal of that
essay? The goal of that essay is for the
student to demonstrate to me that they
have read and properly understood a
book. Okay? Now, it's great if they
develop somewhat original arguments, but
I don't really think, especially at the
undergraduate level, I don't think
professors are really uh holding out for
anything too novel or surprising in
their arguments. Really, what we're
assessing is did you do the work? So,
that's the purpose of most of the
writing that you've done through school.
And in order to get good grades on those
assignments, you had to satisfy certain
reader functions. Right? I'm your
reader. I'm looking for certain
information and you need to give me that
information in the right place in order
for me to give you a good grade. And so
through that process, I think students
learn a lot of bad habits. And on behalf
of all English professors, I just have
to issue an apology here because this
kind of writing has led many writers
astray. Right? In the real world,
readers are not your teachers. So one
thing is they're not being paid to read
your work. they can go at any moment and
especially in this era of you know Tik
Tok and all the other forms of
entertainment that we have reading is a
pretty tall order right they need to
find they need to perceive something of
value in there that they're going to
trade their attention for so the school
problem here is that you learn to write
for people who had to read your work but
in reality your reader is busy skeptical
and very quick to leave if they don't
find your writing useful or insightful
They don't really care how much you
know. They care about how that
information will help them. So, imagine
this. This actually happened to me
earlier today, but imagine it's you. So,
you go online and you want to learn
about how to fix a leaky sink in the
kitchen. My sink is leaking, so I had to
go through this today. And what you're
hoping for is a quick solution. But what
do you find? A long article with intros,
backstory, and too much information,
right? writers on blogs, they have to do
this because they want to expose you to
a number of ads and that kind of thing.
So, whenever you click on a blog, you
get all this background information, all
the context, all this stuff. Ultimately,
nobody's really reading that, but as a
reader, you know how annoying that is,
right? You've come to this blog because
you're looking for instructions or a
recipe or something like that, but
you're having to sort through all this
information just to find the thing that
you're looking for. And that's exactly
what your readers are doing too. And
really what we're talking about here is
the difference between knowledge and
value. So the school problem is that
we've been trained to demonstrate our
knowledge. And by the way, like I I
don't imagine that writers on, you know,
Substack or whatever have this idea that
like I'm going to prove to people how
much I know. That's not exactly what
we're doing. Okay, I understand that.
But it is the there are writing patterns
inherited from that um those writer
functions that that we learned in
school, right? That we've inherited
tendencies from that era into our own
non-fiction writing. And from the reader
perspective, like I don't know who's
reading this stuff because so much of
the stuff that we see published
independently is not taking reader
interests and questions into account. So
many people are just writing about what
they want to write about. And like
again, even though I don't imagine that
these writers are possessed by this idea
that like I'm going to prove to
everybody how much I know, it's not
quite like that. But when you ignore
reader problems and and reader concerns,
then effectively that's the way it comes
across. You're not exactly demonstrating
your knowledge, but all you're offering
is knowledge. All you're offering is
ideas. None of that information is
positioned in a way that the reader will
perceive as valuable. But when you start
thinking about this question of value,
you start to realize that beneath the
language, you know, beneath the
sentences and the paragraphs, there is
this other layer of functions, right?
Expert writing performs functions. It
respects readers time and delivers
knowledge in a way that solves their
problems. Okay? Because if you're using
your writing to build an audience and
establish your authority, then how do
you get trust, right? It's not
credentials. I think that's from another
era, right? Nobody really cares what
university you went to, what your job
is. What they want to see in writing is
value. Okay? So many writers, well, many
would be writers hold themselves back
from writing. They feel like they don't
have enough expertise to share. They
think I'm not interesting. I don't have
anything new to say. I don't have any
interesting ideas. But a way to reframe
this is to say you're not mobilizing
your ideas in a way that readers
perceive as valuable. Right? By using
your writing to generate value, that is
using your writing to solve problems and
answer questions. That's what makes you
an expert. That's where the trust comes
from. Not from your credentials, not
from who you are, but from value. So
your ideas are valuable if you know how
to position them properly. Okay. So the
key thing that you need to think about
whenever you are trying to position your
ideas for value is to ask yourself what
is the benefit that my reader will get
from this or what is the cost that this
idea will help them avoid. Now, there
are some common patterns that you can
use to position your ideas, but I don't
want to get too deep into this world of
templates because I think this kind of
template writing is where a lot of
writers go wrong. This is what's known
as the template trap, right? A lot of
writing instruction offers formulas like
always start with a thesis and every
paragraph needs a topic sentence. Again,
these are rules that are designed for
grading and not for real readers. Like
these structures serve a certain kind of
reader. That's your teacher, right? Your
teacher has a grade sheet. They're
trying to give you a grade for
organization and stuff. And so, you use
your writing to match those reader
expectations. And you did that well. But
the point here is that now you have a
different reader and they're using a
different rubric, a very self-centered
rubric, right? their own problems and
their own concerns and they're using
that rubric to assess the quality of
your writing. So, you want to make sure
that your writing patterns aren't
matching the one from Mrs. Thistlebosome
in second grade who taught you how to
write, but is matching the expectations
of your reader. So, here's a quick
example of what I meant by functions.
And whenever you understand this, it's
going to help you ditch this template
model and start to organize your writing
in terms not of structures, but of
functions. All right? So, you go to a
Starbucks and you order a coffee. Now,
right away, you can predict exactly how
this conversation goes. The barista is
going to say something very predictable.
Hi, welcome to Starbucks. Can I take
your order? What are you going to say?
Well, I'm here in South Korea, so you're
probably going to say ice americano
because that's all Koreans drink.
Summer, winter, doesn't matter. It's got
to be ice americano. So, you order an
ice americano. And what does she say?
Tall size. She says, "Yeah, tall size."
Okay. And then what's she going to say
for here or to go? It's so predictable.
Right now, this is called a genre. This
is a genre. Two people are participating
in a genre. And although the language
forms might change, especially if you go
to a different cafe, right? If you go to
another cafe, they're not going to call
it a tall size, they're going to call it
a large size or all kind. So all kinds
of little surface level tricks, but
you're going to be moving through the
same functions, right? There's going to
be the greeting function, the order
function, the confirmation function, the
purchase function. These are the
different functions in the genre. So
although the surface level language
might change depending on the context
and the people involved and everything
the functions are going to remain
consistent and here's an example of what
happens if that those functions change.
All right. So, example two. You go into
Starbucks. She says, "Hi, welcome to
Starbucks. What's your favorite color?"
Okay, that's weird. But why is that
weird? All right, let's think about it
now. Let's look at the surface level.
Let's look at that question. What's your
favorite color? Nothing wrong with it,
right? No grammar mistakes. Could have
been an A+ from chat GBT, right? Amazing
writing. But the reason that it's weird
is that it doesn't serve a reader or in
that case listener function, right? In a
genre, like genres exist to help people
cooperate and come to a shared goal. So
in the case of Starbucks, there's the
goal of a purchase. And in the case of
an essay, there's going to be the goal
of either better understanding or better
um like uh solving a practical problem,
which is like changing your your
behavior about something. So depending
on the genre, there is going to be a
different goal and there are going to be
different functions that help both
people come to that goal. And so the
reason it's weird at Starbucks for her
to ask, "What's your favorite color?" is
that that question doesn't serve any
discernable function within the genre of
ordering a coffee. Right? every function
in that genre of ordering a coffee is
helping each of you come one step closer
to that goal. So that's the reason why
that situation at Starbucks is so
strange and kind of disappointing,
right? It throws you totally off course.
The thing is the same thing is happening
in your writing if you ignore these
functions. And that's the way that
readers work. Like readers don't care
about templates. They don't care about
structure. The the structure of your
paragraph or the template that you
picked up from this PDF download or
whatever. They don't care about that,
right? What do readers care about? They
care about relevance. The relevance of
whatever language is there in terms of
how it's helping them achieve their
goal. All right? So, following these
templates is just going to make your
writing inflexible and robotic. I'm
thinking now of that great scene of um
Jim Carrey in uh The Truman Show.
>> Why don't you let me fix you some of
this new Moco drink? All natural cocoa
beans from the upper slopes of Mountain
Nicaragua. No artificial sweeteners.
>> What the hell are you talking about?
Who you talking to?
>> I've tasted other cocoos. This is the
best.
>> All right. Like, who are you talking to?
What are you What are you talking about?
Right. When people follow these
templates, it's like, okay, good. Your
writing looks like language. It seems
like language, but it's not talking to
anybody. It's not meeting the reader
where they are. Effective writing does
something. It helps the writer and the
reader achieve a mutual goal. And it
makes these moves almost like a dance.
Like in a dance, there's a coordination
between these two parties. One moves,
the other moves. They move together and
they're both moving toward a shared
goal. So, here's how you can adapt your
writing to your reader. Now again the
first phase of writing is just for you
but what I'm talking about here is
whenever you're adapting your ideas into
something that you're going to publish
right something outward-f facing well in
that case you want to get very clear on
what am I trying to do in the in the
world of non-fiction that's usually just
one thing you're going to be persuading
the reader right now some of you are
writing non-fiction for entertainment
and um good luck with that I mean I I
don't really think a lot of people are
reading for non-fiction for
entertainment these days. So, in
general, I'm going to say that
non-fiction writing is going to be for
persuasion. Now, that's what you're
trying to do. And so, if you're writing
with the goal of persuasion, then you
need to think, who is my reader and
where are they right now? It's just like
Starbucks. You have to start at the
beginning, right? You have to start with
a greeting function. You have to bring
them into your world. And then based on
the way they respond to those early
functions, you're going to have to plan
out the kind of structure of your piece,
right? It's like, I'm going to say this,
and then the reader is probably going to
say that, and then they're going to have
this question, so I'm going to make sure
I address that now, but I don't really
think they're going to agree with this
part of it. So, right, like you're
you're going to structure your whole
text in this kind of decision tree based
on the journey that you expect the
reader to have as you both move toward
your goal. And the goal is to bring them
to the understanding that you yourself
have, the one that you generated through
your freewriting. But you've got to do
that on their terms. You've got to meet
the reader where they are and then take
them step by step. Answer their
questions, address their objections, and
walk with them until you both arrive
safely at the point. So, you need to
think like, do they have any
reservations? Do they already agree with
the premise of uh this idea? Do I need
to warm them up? Are they going to be
resistant to this? You know, is this
idea quite dear to them or are they
looking for a critique? Do they kind of
have a vague sense that maybe this idea
is wrong and they're looking for a good
model of an argument about it? Right? Do
do you need to address any
counterarguments? And if so, which ones?
Right? And to be frank, templates are
for dummies. You don't need them. So,
set them aside because you already know
your stuff and you know your reader. So
just write to that person because
writing is language and language is
social. So when I'm talking about
functions here, I'm just talking about
all the same social functions that you
would take whenever you were trying to
persuade a certain kind of person to
accept your ideas as true. Because good
writing puts the reader first. But AI
writing ignores readers altogether. And
while they might speed up your writing,
what I'm seeing is many writers getting
blown off course. So, watch this video
next because it's going to show you how
to ditch these AI writing tools and get
back to what really counts, which is
valuable writing for specific readers.
So, be sure to go check it out.